hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll
chances are that the technology that
you're using right now to listen to this
podcast was built somewhere else it's
very likely that whatever country
the phone or tablet or computer you're
using to hear me talk right now was
assembled in a different country than
you're living in right now
if not then some piece of it was some
dongle or some wire or something like
that we take for granted that we rely on
stuff whether it's high-tech stuff or
clothing or everyday household
appliances that was built and
manufactured and assembled somewhere
else
since we've had a pandemic and we've
been in lockdown we've been increasingly
used to having stuff delivered directly
to our door whether it's books or
groceries or food for the evening
this is an incredibly complicated system
as you might imagine and it's really
kind of a monument to human ingenuity
that we've built a system of global
commerce that really uses the whole
globe that we build things in one place
we get the raw materials in another
place we consume them in another place
so how does all this work this is the
problem tackled by christopher mims who
is a journalist at the wall street
journal in his new book called arriving
today from factory to front door why
everything has changed about how and
what we buy i'm sure you remember the
ever given disaster right or at least
snafu maybe not disaster but this giant
container ship that got stuck in the
suez canal a few months ago and slowed
down all of global commerce so that's a
reminder on the one hand that there are
fragile points in this system but it's
also just amazing to look at these ships
right these gi humongous vessels stacked
with these containers and these
containers are part of the intermodal
transport system the the containers the
boxes that are on the ships need to be
unloaded incredibly quickly in some very
busy port and then stacked onto trucks
trailers and then taken somewhere else
usually to be unpacked and put on
different trucks and all this is just
incredibly interconnected uh incredibly
time sensitive and it's still incredible
flux we're not done yet we're not done
yet innovating how all this works so the
subject here is industrial ecology
how you build the stuff how you ship it
and the ways in which this search for
ever more efficiency and productivity
have shaped how you work how you work in
a factory in a manufacturing center or
also just in a distribution center
increasingly these days
and
there's look i'm not gonna sugarcoat it
it's a little dehumanizing some of these
stories about what it's like to work in
a distribution center or work as a as a
trucker or a driver for a delivery
service
really call into question the job we're
doing as a society in providing people
with um
good jobs that are fulfilling in
different ways and and on the one hand
let me say that a lot of the structure
is invisible to most of us you know like
if we're not in that business or
whatever we sort of take it for granted
uh and we think about us and them and
it's a very different world on the other
hand i think and hope that there are
people out there who are
long-haul truckers or delivery people
right now listening to the mindscape
podcast and so
this episode is dedicated to you because
you play a crucially important role in
how our society as a whole runs and i
would like your conditioned life to be a
little bit better i'm not sure how much
influence i have over that but it's
something to shoot for the end of the
episode christopher and i will talk
about ways we can improve the current
system uh there are things that are just
inevitable also things that are our
choices and we can make better so we're
gonna try to figure out how to do that
let's go
[Music]
christopher mims welcome to the
mindscape podcast thanks for having me
sean
so i don't want to actually accuse you
of being responsible for the pandemic
that we're all suffering through right
now but it certainly is convenient uh
that in the time when we're all reliant
on things suddenly appearing to our
house from amazon or from delivery
services or whatever you've written a
book about the process by which things
appear at our house so yeah how much of
this is good planning and how much of
this is just the the cosmic wheel
spinning in unpredictable ways it does
quite make me question whether i'm the
only conscious being in the universe and
i'm just manifesting all of this or
because yeah it sort of it is absolutely
bizarre that on a whim
at a super nerdy whim i said i want to
understand where my stuff comes from
this almost childlike impulse and then i
was like i'm gonna write a long
explainer of that a book length
explainer of that and in the middle of
researching and writing it the pandemic
hit and global supply chains seized up
and then exploded and then the debris
fell over all of us
and
and my reporting went on and and then
suddenly i was reporting in the middle
of that
and having absolutely surreal
conversations with
the people responsible for cleaning up
that mess which i'll never forget
from the point of view of the inside of
this whole supply chain was it a were
there dramatic changes because of the
pandemic or was it just like more
intensity to get stuff to people um you
know it's it's difficult to say whether
the increased intensity led to a
qualitative change other than things
just not arriving and stuff breaking
down yeah um i think that the systems
were
initially in the pandemic really
performing kind of
as designed and at capacity and so you
know you had
a lot of these you know supply chains
have to be designed for their maximum
throughput
um
and
which is peak season right which is like
when everybody's buying so much stuff
for holidays or whatever
and uh you know because of when the
pandemic hit we were actually in the
what is traditionally the the
lowest point in terms of demand
for the supply chain so the supply chain
was ready in that sense
but the challenge has come since as that
demand has ramped up and honestly
understanding
the scale of that demand and why we're
in this pickle that we're in now it
requires a lot of macroeconomics because
it requires appreciating that a few
percentage points movement
from consumption of services to
consumption of goods along with a bunch
of changes in how we live and work
leads to
demand that so far outstrips the
capacity of global supply chains that
you get what we're in the middle of now
and what really struck me about reading
the book which i really liked is how
much of the whole process that is
required to um
you know get the computer that i'm
talking to you on delivered to my house
is invisible in some sense you know we
do take it for granted and there's a lot
going on of course it's obvious that
there's a lot going on but when you dig
into it it's you use the phrase
industrial ecology when we were uh
emailing about this and
it's extremely apt because it's not
entirely or even mostly planned from the
top down right it's sort of a million
different
networks have to work together and they
arise in some somewhat organic way
yeah i'm currently
just loving the dickens out of uh the
audiobook of merlin man's
uh entangled life which is about
fungi and how we rely on them and you
know he studied the ecology of these
fungi in tropical rainforest where they
are part of what is known as the wood
wide web and they are
communicating uh what are analogous to
impulses on our nervous system between
trees messages also obviously uh
transporting a lot of nutrients
and the global supply chain is a lot
like the the network of mycorrhizae that
are underneath our feet and which 90 of
all plants depend on
in that um
yeah it is it's not top down the
different segments kind of communicate
with each other at the point of you know
a port or a warehouse or a truck as
goods are moved from one to the other
but each one of them um is uh
kind of self-contained and it is also a
distinct
marketplace like there's nobody who's
cornered the market on ocean shipping
or
trucking or even you know e-commerce as
big as amazon is so every single one of
these
is a very complicated marketplace where
the price of everything is constantly
changing obviously people buy contracts
for long-term shipping like i want so
many shipping containers on this ship
yeah six months from now or whatever but
a lot of it is the so-called spot market
and that's what's been going crazy
because this ecology
um
is just getting overwhelmed and so of
course you know economics it's also
social science the result is that you
know prices go crazy or their shortages
and there's so many different parts of
this i guess uh i want to start with my
favorite part which is the shipping and
the transport part i mean you mentioned
right at the beginning of the book
something that is apparently a cliche or
a standard story in your world which i
not known about the fish
if you fish some salmon off of the coast
of scotland maybe it's salmon maybe some
other kind of fish and then you buy it
in a super cod and then you buy it in
the supermarket in scotland uh
unbeknownst to you it's visited china in
between when it was caught and when it
arrived in your supermarket yes it it
was frozen it went to china it was
filleted
and then it's shipped back you know in
that same cold chain to scotland because
the the cost of labor uh is so much
lower there um so it's like this 20 000
mile journey for your cod or whatever
that was caught very nearby um i think
that that shows kind of the absurdity
of
global supply chains i mean is it absurd
or is it just really efficient you know
before the pandemic
um
there was enough capacity that it cost
two dollars to send a flat screen tv
from a port in china to the port of los
angeles and the united states um now
obviously it only cost two dollars
because it's stuffed with hundreds of
other flat screen tvs in a big shipping
container
um but
you know
what that cost doesn't reflect of course
are all the externalities right like all
of the fossil fuels
you know all of the labor
which you know some of the workers in
that supply chain are working under less
than ideals
circumstances
um
you know but we it's kind of like we've
we've got the science so let's do it
like we have the technology
um and of course now we're in a very
different place where the cost of
shipping that television is going to be
10 times what it was before so it may no
longer be profitable to
fillet that cod
in china and you know the short term
result is well maybe there's no filet
cod in your supermarket in scotland i
mean there's all kinds of shortages
happening in the uk now because of a
trucker shortage you know the long term
is
maybe people start to
relocalize
or or as they say re-shore those supply
chains
um
it would certainly be less absurd from
an energy expended perspective
what what exactly are you referring to
when you say that uh it will soon be 10
times as expensive to do that shipping
it is 10 times as expensive now the spot
market for a shipping container if you
wanted to
transport a shipping container from
you know one of the biggest ports in
china across the pacific
to a west coast port in the us usually
it's the port of la long beach which is
the biggest port in the united states in
the before times it would cost you maybe
two thousand dollars now on the spot
market it'll cost you
sixteen thousand dollars twenty thousand
dollars it's so expensive
that a lot of shippers have just thrown
up their hands and said forget it let's
just put it on an airplane but the
problem is
because there's so much less domestic
not domestic international travel
a lot of that airplane shipping was just
in the spare capacity in the belly of
passenger jets so
people are really stuck but what is the
reason for this growth in cost is that
the pandemic or something else
so this is the thing that is difficult
to appreciate
there has
we what we have as much as anything as
much as we have a supply of shipping
crunch
we have an explosion in demand for
shipping yeah this is because lockdowns
led so many more of us to um sort of buy
things via e-commerce e-commerce supply
chains are biased toward you know things
coming from china and east asia and
south asia and southeast asia
and in addition
there was this thing that happened where
at the beginning of the pandemic
shippers truckers etc
um companies canceled their orders
because what they thought was gonna
happen at the beginning of the pandemic
was a sequel to the great recession
right
you know like where lehman brothers
collapsed and all that so everybody
thought oh god we're gonna have this
huge recession so let's pull back our
orders let's let's not book any more um
you know shipping containers and trucks
and what what not but instead what
happened was you saw this huge surge in
demand you know and part of this is a
big part of this is people just stopped
going out so that they just started
buying stuff yeah another part is you
know obviously like all those uh the
stimis those stimulus checks helped but
i really think what happened more than
anything else and this comes from recent
reporting i've been doing talking to
economists and stuff
people have changed
their lives more than we appreciate so
the bureau of labor statistics says that
only maybe 14 of people are still
working from home but that could be an
artifact of how they ask the question if
you look at it there's a gallop data
that came out yesterday which says that
the number is more like twice that
so we may already be approaching the
maximum number of people
who are in jobs who can work from our
working home part of the time and what
that's leading to is just this huge
lifestyle change so one
one
sociologist wonk person called it family
insourcing and i think whether or not
you have kids we've all had the
experience of being like you know what
i'm gonna do more stuff at home i need a
new set of knives i need some outdoor
furniture i need a desk for my kid i
need a webcam and so
that demand
and then the ability to to do that
spending because nobody's going to
disneyland or whatever has just shifted
so much spending to goods right and
those goods have to get into our country
on shipping containers and that whole
system
is not designed to ramp up quickly and
it's impossible to ramp it up quickly
because what are you going to do are you
going to put in another order for
another ocean-going ship that's
literally three football fields long and
15 stories tall okay great well hyundai
heavy industries will get you that ship
right away in four years so
that's a big part of the problem
what's the secret to your best night's
sleep first toss out your memory foam
and upgrade to awara the luxury hybrid
mattress with natural foam and new
zealand wool fiber awara features
premium sri lankan latex and wrapped
coil springs to provide contour and a
touch of bounce for supportive sleep
throughout the night awara is known for
that weightless feeling you get neutral
spine alignment so no sinking or pulling
on the natural curve of your back your
weight will be evenly distributed from
head to toe with a touch of bounce you
simply can't get with old-fashioned
memory foam mattresses
and there's a best in the industry 365
night trial no questions asked if you
don't like it awara will take it back
even if it's 364 days later for a
limited time you'll get 499 dollars in
free accessories two natural latex
pillows cotton sheets and a waterproof
mattress protector with every mattress
purchased and feel good knowing awara
plants 10 trees with every purchase so
sleep better knowing you just planted a
small forest to redeem go to
www.awarasleep.com that's awa
rasleep.com discount auto apply to
checkout
okay good so it's just supply and demand
and the pandemic and this shift in
lifestyle which as you note might not go
back i mean i think just to sort of put
things in context here
over the course of this conversation
we'll be we'll be
bumping into various horrific aspects of
this whole supply chain
but we do as consumers benefit from it i
mean like you said uh we buy stuff i
mean not only the obvious stuff but i
did upgrade my kitchen utensils during
the pandemic because i was using them a
lot more frequently right that kind of
thing goes invisible but it can
definitely lead to a lot more demand
yes because i mean i mean
this is
economists call this multiplexing when
when one good can be used over and over
again and it's just a much more
efficient use of that good
and when we were all going to offices
and sharing a coffee maker we were
multiplexing that coffee maker well now
that we're all at home
well
you know we all need coffee makers
60 new coffee makers got ordered or
whatever
so for everyone that used to be in the
office we we all um
i had this experience during the
pandemic of uh watching on tenterhooks
the the drama in the suez canal with the
ever given uh ship being stuck and
when that happened like it it sent me on
a little bit of a a trip down the rabbit
hole concerning containerization
and this is something that i just became
absolutely fascinated with like i could
have the whole podcast uh conversation
about containerization but we'll try to
get other things first but the very idea
which i'm sure i knew
but hadn't quite appreciated that those
boxes those containers that are on the
ships are the same boxes that are being
uh pulled by trucks right like it's
literally exactly the same box you pick
it from the ship put it on the truck put
it on the train and this is not
automatic or or natural it happened
starting in the 1950s and and it changed
everything uh
and the word container is not just a box
containing things it's a very specific
kind of container these intermodal
things that go on ships and everything
so i mean put into your own words a
little bit about how that did change the
whole supply chain that we rely on yeah
i mean i think containerization is it's
actually a much deeper phenomenon
because this is also how the internet
works right like the internet the
underlying protocol
it turns data into discrete packets
that then are all handled the same right
um so anytime you want to create a
system whether it's the internet or a
you know a network of fungi in the
forest or a shipping network you want to
containerize things so you have like a
standard thing that all the different
modes of transport can handle and that's
called intermodal right so a shipping
container can go on a truck on a ship on
a train
um
and all of the cranes can be
standardized
etc right it's like it's like any other
standard like you know that you're the
plug in your wall like if every
electrical plug in every house was
putting at a different voltage like
we would never you know
our modern world wouldn't work so that
standard um you know came about as you
said starting in the 50s
really in the 60s it picked up
because um there's this guy named
malcolm mclean there's an amazing book
about him by mark levin called the box
um
and
he just had this vision let's stick
stuff in containers that can travel
between
you know ships and trucks primarily and
everybody was like okay we kind of agree
with you and we've experimented with
this a little bit here and there but
we have a different standard you know
these are different dimensions of a box
that we want and ultimately he won
in no small part because
the united states government needed to
move an enormous amount of material
into vietnam for the vietnam war so he
got that contract and they're like cool
we'll use your shipping containers
you know it gave him enough
kind of startup capital to build ships
that were designed just to handle
shipping containers
of a specific size that could then be
unloaded by cranes of a standard size
and then before you know it
those cranes were
being installed in ports all over the
u.s and then eventually the world and
then what happened was you know people
examined the throughput of these ports
and it was so much higher than the old
way because the old way was
you have a bunch of barrels and sacks
and god knows what else
and then an army of
men has to go into the hold of that ship
and haul it out it usually it used to
take like two weeks to unload a ship
a containerized ship a j even a big one
they can unload it in 24 hours yeah and
a big one is really really big
enormous 10 000 40 foot containers on
the biggest of ships i said this earlier
but it bears repeating three football
fields long
15 stories tall when you are next to one
of these as i've been both on the water
and on land it it really really feels
like like when you stand like on a long
block in like new york city or chicago
or some place like that and you're just
looking up at these kind of hulking
buildings and there's a whole block of
them because it's as big as the sky it's
they're literally as big as the empire
state building laid on its side
and that
is is you know
the most efficient way to move
adam's mass on the surface of the earth
that we've ever invented because of all
the fun newtonian physics of water and
all the rest well and what's interesting
one of the many things that are
interesting to me about this is
that there needed to be some kind of
phase transition right like it's easy
for everyone to individually load their
sacks of grain onto a ship but for the
world to agree we're going to use this
kind of standardized container
they might all agree that if we all did
that it would be great but someone has
to do it first right when and there is
very expensive when you first do it and
basically like like you say it was this
one guy malcolm mclean he just really
pushed for it he was the right place at
the right time with the vietnam war
contract and that changed the world yeah
i mean it's such a great argument in
favor of
standards and open standards you know i
mean it's it's on a par with like tim
berners-lee and like the world wide web
and html and being like let's all agree
that this is the standard and this is
how we're going to render web pages and
everybody gets to use this and then we
can all interface with each other and
then boom globalization and the
the magic of the container is you know
it gets loaded i'm stating this as a
statement but correct me if i'm wrong
here like
it gets loaded in vietnam or wherever uh
and then it might not be opened or
unloaded until it arrives at some
factory or or some facility in utah or
whatever it just travels across the
world and who knows what's inside
someone knows what's inside but the
people who load it don't need to know
yeah the only wrinkle i would add is
that
a lot of those containers
um unless they're traveling on a train
because trains are
so so efficient um will actually be
unloaded
not that far from the port
and then put into all the contents will
be put into the back of
a semi-trailer and the reason that
happens is
containers are
heavy
uh because you know they have to
withstand an ocean
uh you know traveling across the ocean
so for that reason just to save on fuel
and all the rest a lot of containers get
emptied in these vast warehouses that
you know are kind of invisible to us
in you know california's inland empire
let's say okay um and and and and the
materials cross-docked as it's put
into uh you know along the back of a
long-haul truck because a semi-trailer
is super lightweight it's very thin it's
very i mean it's strong because it's got
a metal frame but it's very very very
thin and lightweight yeah so i feel like
when i'm driving around la i'm at the
center of global commerce sometimes and
and i've noticed since i became
fascinated by these containers that
some trucks are really they're clearly
containers uh and some are not and what
you're telling us is that there is sort
of an economy to only
actually lugging the
intermodal container a short way before
you distribute it to more efficient
ground transportation systems yeah yeah
exactly and and and and again the
exception of that is trains and we
shouldn't forget that
by ton mile
we move almost as much material in the
us by train as we do by truck it's just
tends to be different stuff it's like
commodities or you know frankly a lot of
it's coal
yeah okay but um yeah
a lot of that stuff gets put into a
different kind of box when it goes on
the back of a truck and is there some
feeling for
you know uh the most
important or popular trade routes and
the most important kinds of cargo i mean
obviously it's everything in some sense
but is it dominated by a small number or
is it really just this network that you
know every big city has a port and it
connects with every other big city well
this is the thing that's interesting
about containers
and containerized shipping is that it
exactly maps to
the pattern of global trade right so we
have a big
trade deficit with china right we buy
way more than from them than they buy
from us but what does that actually look
like well the physical reality of it is
shipping containers worth of goods
that's why so many full containers cross
the ocean from these giant ports in
in china i think the seven biggest ports
in the world are all in china
um you know across the pacific to the
port of l.a long beach i mean there's
also they can also go to oakland or
ports in canada and places like that or
they might go around and go to like
savannah but um
then you know one of the challenges we
have right now with global shipping is
that
what we're selling back to china
is
you know a lot of it's like intellectual
property
and software movies and cloud services
things that do not need to go into
shipping containers
um
so
so then the problem is well you got all
these empty shipping containers like
who's gonna ship them back and remember
like we talked about earlier there's no
top-down authority that's like i wave my
fiat wand and say all these
empty shipping containers need to go
back
on another route like they they take a
kind of more tortured route back to
china and so that's why there's this
imbalance just as we have a trade
imbalance there's this imbalance of
containers and people are like oh crap
we don't have enough containers and
china's like oh crap we're making
containers as fast as we can but there's
this terrible inefficiency in the system
where it's like we have a lot of
containers
they're in the wrong place like
somebody's got to figure out how to get
these back and we have ways to get them
back it's just that those are broken
like so many other parts of the supply
chain and is there a simple
way of characterizing the sense in which
china is the center of a lot of this is
that they're i mean you know our
t-shirts and everything say made in
china but uh is that just because labor
is cheaper uh is it going to continue
that way my feeling is that china is
trying to sort of
upgrade their their uh job force to go
from mindless labor to other kinds of
things so will it is it a temporary
thing where all these things are made in
china and soon they'll be made elsewhere
um
so it started because china had uh a
you know cheap labor but also you know
it's just a big centrally controlled
economy
where you know the communist party can
just sort of dictate well we're going to
prop up this industry or we're going to
build these kind of factories or
whatever
um but
even as wages rise in china there is a
stickiness to things still being made
there
because it requires expertise to make
many things in our modern world they're
very very complicated so even if
manufacturers would like to
move the manufacturer of say consumer
electronics from china to southeast asia
or even you know south asia
um
they they have to do it one piece at a
time starting with the least complicated
part of that process which usually is
the assembly by hand of the iphone or
the
samsung phone or the airpods at the end
of that manufacturing process but those
microchips and like other
you know uh tricky to make components
they may still be made in china and then
shipped over there um in order to uh
because that's where the expertise is
right and and and and
the funny thing is that like
expertise
um
you know it's like water or something
like it sort of like accumulates in
these
unexpected places
uh it turns out that malaysia
is where um
the world's microchips are packaged and
packaging a microchip means taking that
silicon chip and putting into the little
thing that you've seen when you've like
busted open an old computer where it
looks like a bug
and it's black and has little
legs which are you know the electrical
connections chip packaging is really
important that's done in malaysia
malaysia had a bunch of shutdowns
recently so um it it caused another
kind of mini chip shortage not because
there weren't enough chips but because
there wasn't enough capacity to package
them in malaysia so what ends up
happening is even as china is trying to
move up
the
uh kind of scale of development to you
know more
like you know software engineering or
whatever else production of cultural
capital whatever it is that the us is
doing
um
you know there is that stickiness and it
tends to have this effect of just
lengthening supply chains and making
them even more complicated and more
vulnerable like it's a bit comical like
that's not the only effect it has
because because people who do logistics
for a living get wise to this and are
like hmm we really should spend the
extra money required to like
vertically integrate this all on our
shores but do you make it but that's
been the near term it's a very
interesting point the combination of the
fact that expertise pools in certain
geographic locations plus the fact that
shipping is relatively cheap right i
mean that's the lesson of the of the cod
from scotland um
creates this absolutely byzantine
network that i think that we're not
usually aware of of how how many trips
the individual pieces of something have
to make you know like it's built
somewhere packaged somewhere else you
know put in a
cardboard and plastic container
somewhere else etc before it gets to us
it's just cheaper to do things in
different parts of the world than to
build a a a
i don't know a factory or whatever it is
a facility locally the shipping is the
easy part
yeah and and there's so many fascinating
examples of that you know and the more
complicated the object the more of those
dependencies it has i mean one of my
favorite examples is like okay let's say
you want to build like the cpu of a
smartphone or whatever okay
starting point if we're not going to go
back to the birth of the universe is
um
is ultra pure
quartz
sand
in of all places appalachia
now that quartz sand is going to get
transported somewhere where it can be
melted down and grown into a crystal
that could be australia
now that incredibly pure crystal of
silicon is gonna be transported you know
uh elsewhere it could be another country
but let's just say it goes to taiwan
then the crystal is sliced into wafers
and then you know tsmc's fabs in taiwan
it's etched
now those
chips are broken up and as we just
discussed they're packaged in malaysia
and then they're gonna get transported
to shenzhen
where finally they're gonna get stuck
into a phone
that is the that is the trip
just to get this thing assembled oh and
by the way it might then travel from
shenzhen to lake india because so much
phone assembly is being done there or in
vietnam
and then it's gonna cross the ocean back
to us
so just to imagine like if you were
trying to design the most rube
goldbergian
and the most vulnerable
to to
uh like trade wars actual wars global
pandemics it's uh i mean honestly it is
a miracle
that that like we haven't run out of
everything by now when you think about
it it shows that there is a lot of
flexibility and elasticity in these
markets yeah no but it does seem
very fragile in a way i mean that's the
difference i guess with a biological
network a biological network like you
you compared it to the the fungi et
cetera or the networks in our bodies but
they're sort of
evolved to be resilient right um because
you know whatever kind of redundancy
that uh is useful to survive a little
bit longer might be selected by natural
selection whereas here there's just one
global supply chain and you can imagine
their critical points where it could
break down catastrophically yeah i mean
like you're student of evolution i mean
you know that one of the major reasons
that we think species go extinct is that
they over specialize then the ecosystem
changes and then it's like boom adios
like you're the dinosaurs the asteroid
just arrived like see you later
um
you know and then the the weed species
of the world kind of take over so yeah i
mean i think that the the this whole
system is in a place now where people
are recognizing these vulnerabilities
like the tim cooks of the world have
like woken up and that's why to go back
to microchips you have intel
and others being like you know we're
going to spend i forget with the figures
tens of billions of dollars
to build more fabrication capacity
in the us
tsmc which is you know they make almost
all the the high-end chips that we all
rely on
they're building a new fabrication plant
in
japan they just announced interestingly
that plant is not for the latest
generation of chips it's for the old
chips that the automakers need and and
can't get enough of so people are kind
of saying oh this needs to be more
resilient and the one way that you build
resilience of course is redundancy
after hours of dedicated research
nothing feels better than the
satisfaction of finally finding the
information you've been looking for you
get that same incredible feeling when
you're finally able to hire the next
great person after a candidate search
within deed if you're hiring you need
indeed because indeed is a hiring
partner that gets you what you really
want a short list of quality candidates
as fast as possible where you can do it
all attract interview and hire all the
same website at indeed so don't struggle
on your own to find quality candidates
indeed can help you hire the right
people right now indeed partners with
you on every step of the hiring process
so you can find talent with the skills
you need through tools like indeed
instant match assessments and virtual
interviews get started right now with a
75 dollar sponsored job credit to
upgrade your job post at indeed.com
mindscape get a 75 credit at indeed.com
mindscape indeed.com
mindscape offer valid through december
31st terms and conditions apply need to
hire you need indeed
okay let's let's switch to um some of
you already mentioned very briefly but
clearly is an overarching theme in the
book which is
uh time
saving time making things happen as
quickly as possible and you mentioned
the the chaos not the chaos but the
activity at a port like long beach or
l.a or shenzhen or whatever
and it's kind of awesome to behold you
see these pictures of you know what
looks like acres of shipping containers
lying on the ground and i read an
interesting statistic here that the
average time to unload a container from
a ship in north america is 76 seconds
in northern europe it's 46 seconds and
in asia it's 27 seconds so i thought 76
seconds was pretty good uh but they're
they're even much faster in asia so uh
it reminds me a little bit of you know
trying to get to a sports stadium for
the big event or trying to park at an
airport where you have many many people
trying to converge on a tiny place and
there must be both science and
engineering that goes into figuring out
the most optimal way to get this stuff
to happen yeah and there's a lot of fun
math which i think
you probably enjoy
um you know like it goes back to
um
i think it was i think it was claude
shannon
and um
you know uh
having to
the the the problem of figuring out how
big
of uh uh uh or or how many
uh
i forget the name of them the people who
like use this uh direct phone calls in
the old days yeah or switchboard
operations operators how many yes how
many switchboard operators do you need
so that you know x number of people
in a town
uh will be able to connect 90 of the
time
that turns out to be this really
interesting mathematical problem and
that kind of uh math
which
among other things led to so-called
queueing theory just literally the math
of waiting in lines
is absolutely integral to the entire
switching because every everywhere you
go in the supply chain everybody's
waiting in a line you're a ship waiting
off the shore to get on on on
in and then you know once you pull these
containers off as quickly as possible
and maybe you're using robots to help
you do that faster
now you have a whole new cue every
terminal in a port
is just a big messy
three-dimensional
line
cue where you know containers are
stacked on top of each other and they're
moved around
and they need to be
in the right place which is on top of a
stack
not that far from the far side of the
terminal on the at the moment that a
truck pulls up to grab that container
and then cart it off you know to a to a
warehouse and the thing is if you fully
unloaded a modern container ship
i did the math it's in the book and i
can't remember exactly the math but if
you fully unloaded a modern container
ship and you allow a reasonable distance
between the trucks doing it
the line of trucks would be like 50
miles long
that's the length of your queue from one
ship per ship and so now you can you can
see the the sort of challenge of making
this work and you can also see the value
of why so many ports are turning to
automation
to do things like
groom
the the yard of containers which just
means rearranging them continuously with
these big robots
so that the containers are kind of
moving through with the least number of
total moves
smoothly from where they're pulled off
the ship to where they're put onto a
truck and that's just one of the queuing
problems right and there's queueing
problems throughout the whole thing and
it's nevertheless a
interplay of human judgment and
automation like you have this
fascinating story of just
piloting the ship into the port right
like there needs to be a highly paid uh
ships pilot who is local to the port who
goes on a little tugboat or whatever
climbs onto this big container ship and
then pilots it in
yes i mean the harbor pilot thing
blew me away because
this the simplest way to put this is
that for every for ninety percent of the
stuff that you own which comes on ships
ninety percent of everything as rose
george's book is called
um
someone had to risk their life at least
at that one moment to get it to you and
what i mean is
that to transfer the specialized pilot
who knows how to navigate that giant
ship into the very tight confines of a
port
that person had to
um you know motor out to that giant
container ship on what's called a pilot
boat
and then
because the pilot boat's so tiny and the
ship is so big and there's this ocean
swell happening they have to time it
just right where the two ships are
moving up and down and with a different
period
and kind of nimbly hop from the deck of
the pilot boat onto what to this day is
still a rope ladder
and then they got to scramble up the
rope ladder before the swell of the
ocean catches them because if they get
sucked under their survival rate is like
zero so
over the course of a harbor pilot's
career there's a one in 20 chance that
they'll die on the job
and these are not people who are
disposable in any sense i mean no human
life is disposable but in terms of their
expertise because
these are the most experienced pilots in
the world they have to be a an ocean
going pilot for years and years
generally and then they have to pass
this insane test that's like the test
that cabbies have to pass in london to
become cab drivers the knowledge where
they literally fill out by hand a giant
paper map of the port that they're going
to be harbor piloting in and it takes
them like six hours to write in all the
features and the depths and the hazards
so
the things that they do in terms of
steering this boat are are just unreal
you know because it's it's something
with the mass of a skyscraper
and you know the tolerances as they go
under a bridge or the tolerance between
the bottom of the ship
and the bottom of the ship channel could
be like a meter and then they've got to
get it right by the um key side
to within a meter or two
of where it's supposed to land between
two other ships that they don't want to
crash into so that the electricity and
the fuel can be hooked up properly so
it's just like crazy it's like stunt
driving but with a skyscraper and it
doesn't seem like the most rationally
designed system in the world i mean are
ports
constantly being reinvented to be better
or are they just sort of
scrambling as fast as they can to keep
up with the changing global supply chain
i think that they
there is an element of scramble but the
thing is that ports are public
infrastructure
so
you know it's not like amazon's like oh
we need a bigger port i mean we might
get there
but you know the what happens is you get
billions of dollars of public investment
by you know
let's say the state of california in
this case or the cities
because they know that they're going to
recoup it because of taxes and economic
activity but like you know that kind of
investment in expansion takes decades
in order to make these you know the
challenge they have now is that
because it's more efficient and cheaper
for the ocean shippers
these uh container ships have just
gotten bigger and bigger and bigger and
now they're really at the limit of what
these ports can handle
i could talk about the shipping and the
containerization forever so like like i
said but uh we should shift gears a
little bit to the the manufacturing side
of things and as you point out in the
book you know this the issues that were
always there in the factories on the
manufacturing side of things are now
there at the opposite end of the supply
chain in the fulfillment centers right i
mean it's a very it's a full circle kind
of operation but
tell us about frederick winslow taylor
because here's another thing where if
you're in the business this is just like
he's super famous everyone knows him
it's like who's einstein but if you're
not in the business you've never heard
of this guy yeah when for luke winslow
taylor he's like
you know he's like uh what you know what
karl marx is to communism i think taylor
is to
to modern uh kind of
technological industrial capitalism but
his name is not familiar because his
ideas have become the water that we swim
in he was really the first
management consultant and he he invented
this whole idea of like time and motion
studies and speeding up the labor of
people who are in
jobs that involve a lot of routine like
manufacturing that's where he started
and of course you know should be stated
that this was uh one of these moments in
history of like dual discovery like
newton and leibniz both coming up with
calculus around the same time because at
the same time that taylor came up with
all of his ideas
henry ford was
and his team was coming up with the same
ideas in order to get employees to be
able to keep up with the pace of the um
assembly line which he had just invented
uh or borrowed really from
slaughterhouses so
taylorism is just this idea that you can
you can break down you know a job into
these
minute tasks time every single one of
them and come up with better ways to do
it and what it leads to is the speed up
of work and the way that taylorism was
implemented back at the beginning of the
20th century
workers found it so brutal that at the
watertown
armory where it was implemented by the
us government a bunch of them went on
strike and then there were congressional
hearings and congress declared that
taylorism could never again be used
um like anywhere in a federal facility
which is ironic because again now it's
kind of like the way that everything is
run the modern day version of it i call
besosism and businessism is just what's
what happens in amazon fulfillment
centers it's taylorism it's the ideology
of taylor is um kind of carried down to
us through a bunch of other management
consultants
combined with very sophisticated systems
for observing in real time every single
thing a person does right technological
surveillance and then once you have all
that data
you can manage people by algorithm right
so if somebody falls behind in an amazon
fulfillment center it's not their boss
who's like hey work faster back in the
days of taylor it's an algorithm and it
just says hey you spent too much time
off task or it says hey this is your
third warning in two weeks you know
this algorithm is gonna write you up and
then you're gonna go talk to your human
manager
um
so management by algorithm obviously you
see that everywhere now you see it in um
the way that like
uh shifts are scheduled at you know fast
food restaurants the way that um the
pace of work is regulated at fast food
restaurants the way the pace of work is
regulated at call centers
um obviously the way amazon fulfillment
centers are run
and you know part of the kind of great
resignation we're seeing now i think
is people rebelling against that style
of work because it's
you know everybody has a bad day
but if your manager is an algorithm
there's no button you can press on your
app to be like i'm having a bad day give
me a break well that's what's so
crucial about this moment when taylor
comes along and i mean i think that
you're right the impression i got from
reading your book is that henry ford
obviously played a huge role here but
the most striking thing about taylor's
way of doing things was rather than
just telling workers okay this is your
task now do it and even more than just
saying do it fast or we'll fire you or
whatever it was this observation of you
know looking at different workers doing
it different ways figuring out what was
the most efficient way and then not just
telling the workers to do it but do it
in this exact way with this exact
sequence of movements so on the one hand
it makes things a lot more
uh productive efficient on the other
hand it does leech the humanity out of
the human being that is actually doing
this task yeah everything depends on how
much agency
that worker has so i had a really
interesting conversation with you know
some sociologists and labor economists
and they pointed out that
there are industries
like automobile manufacturing
where
you know obviously workers are unionized
so they have a lot of say over the how
their work is done
where
those workers one sort of presented with
hey here's a way to make your work more
efficient what do you think about that
and they can push back on and be like
well this part isn't safe or this part
isn't sustainable you know
telling people hey let's make work more
efficient and safer and more humane
everybody most people will sign up for
that but when workers have
no agency
then what can happen is what we've seen
in amazon's warehouses where
the pace of work and the repetitive
nature of the work which is directly a
product of the automation that's being
incorporated into that work leads to
things like so-called musculoskeletal
disorders i.e you know like carpal
tunnel syndrome whatever because the
human body was not designed to
do this exact same action
i know your viewers can't see it but i'm
picking objects off of the shelf in an
amazon warehouse as quickly as i can
um and repeat that action over and over
and over again and we all know anybody
who's done any athletic activity that
your joints are going to give out if you
do the exact same thing over and over
again for 10 hours a day every work well
you mentioned the fact that
there is a correlation between
increasing automation in these centers
and increasing injury rates in these
centers for the human beings who are
still there i mean is part of that just
that we're in a transitional time and we
haven't yet figured out or the bosses
haven't yet figured out that it's
important to keep your employees healthy
and so let them vary their routines or
vary their tasks or something or is it
just we're going to dispose of these
human beings eventually so who cares i
mean i think that um
amazon
has been in such high growth mode for so
long that the people in charge whether
it was a conscious decision or not
have been
like okay if we're gonna make this
business big and profitable
this is the pace of work that we need to
set and i think the challenge that
amazon has now is they're bigger they're
more mature there's more scrutiny but
just as importantly the labor market is
starting to do its job economics is
working in that um there are so many
fulfillment centers amazon has such a
high demand for workers everyone does
now because as a labor shortage
especially for blue-collar workers
that you know raising wages is no longer
enough if you have a hundred percent
turnover per year which is you know not
at all atypical for these warehouses um
you need to figure out how to hold on to
those workers longer and when every time
your workers organize they're telling
you
our issue's not benefits and wages those
are fine thank you jeff bezos
our issue is working conditions at some
point they have to listen otherwise they
just cannot run their business because
they just can't
recruit and retain they can't recruit
workers fast enough and they can't
retain them long enough because there's
only so many human beings
of working age
in an economy that's just the way it
works well a big part of it uh we should
talk about the the concept of
de-skilling labor i don't know if this
goes back to taylor or whoever but the
idea that we want to take the trickiest
parts of the manufacturing process and
give those to the robots to the
computers and whatever as much as we can
the loom makes it much easier
uh for for
weaving to be done by unskilled laborers
and so you figure well now i can just
replace my workers with anyone if the
parts that they have to do are very
simple but they're still like you say a
bottleneck with the number of people
that exist yeah i mean de-skilling has
been integral to the expansion of amazon
and countless other businesses right
oral fast food industry is built on this
idea that you don't need a skilled fry
cook to make a burger because this
automated grill is doing it for you so
de-skilling is just when you take the
knowledge essentially it's when you take
the knowledge of the human you embody it
in a machine a piece of automation it
doesn't have to be a very smart piece of
automation but it is skilled in the
sense that it can do a job that before
might have been tricky i like that you
mentioned looms because that goes all
the way back to the luddites and ned lud
wanting to smash the automatic limbs
because they were taking away the jobs
of the weavers
but when you de-skill a task you make it
very easy
to recruit new workers
which gives you less incentive to retain
them right so if amazon can train a new
amazon warehouse worker in a day or less
then you know turnover doesn't become a
problem until they run out of new people
to recruit
and i want to you know we skipped over
from sort of um frederick winslow taylor
to jeff bezos but in between there's
this whole
kind of fascinating culture of
management scientific management
strategies right the toyota way
kaizen
lean manufacturing
and how much of these are like really
insightful ways to get manufacturing
done and how many of them are sort of
management fads yeah uh it's difficult
to say because it so much depends on how
they're applied i mean obviously
when um
toyota
came up with their
uh
you know
toyota production system
that is the reason that toyota took over
the global
and especially the us
uh auto market
um
by the same token you know jack welch at
ge came up with this whole idea of six
sigma which just means like
statistically like reducing the error in
your manufacturing process until it's
like
not even there anymore
um
and you know all of a lot of that
or maybe all of it really derived from
yeah this early kind of ideology of
um management consulting because you
know even though taylor you know he
wrote this book scientific management he
wasn't so successful as an individual
at getting companies to adopt this but
his acolytes right um which included
like the gilberths who then had a dozen
kids and then there's a disney movie
called cheaper by the dozen because they
were applying the lessons of scientific
management to managing a household
um
really spread this idea around so so it
is this idea that just kind of gets
expanded on
um
because in some sense you know if you're
especially manufacturing
if you
adhere to these dictates and these
strategies you can
make
an almost defect-free product
consistently right which is the goal of
manufacturing rather than having to kind
of rework it at the end like you know
tesla in the early days um so it does
work
and it does get implemented differently
all over the world so the toyota
production system obviously japan is a
completely different cultural milieu
than the us because at the time the
toyota production system is being ramped
up you know it's a culture of um you
know lifelong employment it's this deep
relationship between the employee and
the employer so
there is more about like let's empower
the worker like if the worker sees
something wrong they get to pull their
little and on flag
and say like hey something's messed up
here
that exact sort of idea set of ideas
got imported into um
amazon by some executives who i talked
to in the book um
you know but it got
mutated in some ways and then became
businessmen
they took out the worker empowerment
part and just put more surveillance in
what do best buy wayfarer marco polo and
among us have in common they trust
lenode as an alternative to the cost and
complexity of the world's largest public
cloud providers
the node makes cloud computing simple
affordable and accessible whether you're
working on a personal project or looking
for someone to manage your company's
infrastructure the node has the pricing
support security and scale you need with
lenode you get consistent and
predictable pricing across 11 global
markets
24x7 by 365 human support rich
documentation and policies and controls
to strengthen your overall security
posture allowing you to grow at your own
pace
users continually rank the node as one
of the leading public cloud providers on
both g2 and trust radius find out why
visit leno.com mindscape that's
l-i-n-o-d-e
dot com slash mindscape and start a free
account today
well and it's not just the need for
speed here although that's very
important but also the need for
predictability you know like you said
before uh we want everything we don't
just want the average time to do
something to be low but it better not
have that much variability around it and
and part of that optimization problem
has helped us create this culture of
just-in-time manufacturing right where
you manufacture something and then
basically ship it to a person rather
than letting it sit in a warehouse for a
long time and again that's great for
efficiency and productivity a little
worrisome when it comes to vulnerable
points in the chain right i mean it's
it's it's pretty straightforward if you
don't have
um
any extra inventory sitting around and
there is a supply shock where you can't
get enough of something or suddenly
it takes you twice as long to get it
across the ocean on a ship
then you know you're screwed you're
going to run out
okay and then the final step um we we're
we've gotten our raw materials we've
shipped them around the world we've made
a product we've shipped it in a
container we sent it to a fulfillment
center and now they're sending it out so
there's a whole another
step of getting the goods to people i
mean and maybe we skipped over the the
trucking step where we get things from
the port to the fulfillment center but
but both that trucking step and then the
delivery step
is just a whole another invisible
culture of of human beings in the united
states that uh you don't paint a very
rosy picture of the life of a of a
delivery person or a trucker i gotta say
yeah
um yeah i mean trucker's really
i mean they um i think what sums it up
there's this amazing 2017
feature in the new york times and you
know one of the truckers that whom they
interviewed said you know we feel like
throwaway people
and um you know it's an industry where
we often hear about oh there's a trucker
shortage but the truth is there's not a
shortage of
people who want to get into trucking
there is a
burnout and a retention crisis there are
three times as many people in the united
states who have the kind of commercial
driver's license required to drive a
truck as there are of working truck
drivers and it's not because they all
retired and are having a nice life and
like the lake of the ozarks now it's
because they burned out or they didn't
even last two weeks and were like this
job sucks i'm getting out of here
and you know frankly i don't think
truckers get very good representation
um you know in congress because this big
lobbying body there it's called the
american trucking association it
represents these really big carriers
but they don't even represent the
majority of the trucking industry most
of the trucking industry is like
individual owner operators small
trucking companies they have their own
lobbying body that
somehow
doesn't get quoted very often
so you know truckers you know they are
here's the typical life of a trucker
right they're on the road 21 days out of
every month that means they're nowhere
near home or their family
they're working 14 hours a day 14 hours
a day
is because the federal government limits
them to 14 hours a day used to be more
they're getting paid by the mile so if
they're sitting at a warehouse where
they have no control over how fast their
truck is being loaded or unloaded
they're not getting paid for that time
um there may not be a place for them to
sleep at night because
there's not enough berths at truck stops
and rest stops so they might have to
illegally park down the side of the
highway you see this once you know that
this is a thing you see it all the time
you're like why is that truck just
parked on the on-ramp or the off-ramp
it's because that poor truck driver
couldn't find anywhere else well and
also by the way i think because maybe
many people don't know this when you say
find a place to sleep you're not talking
about a hotel
they sleep in the truck it's just a
matter of where to park the truck while
you're sleeping yes
um so
and and on top of that i mean i think
there's this impression like oh drive a
truck i can drive like i can do that no
like it is a skilled
job to not kill yourself and other
people because the physics of a of a
fully loaded truck mean that it's gonna
take you you know a football field or
two to stop
um
and uh you know you may be driving in
inclement weather
and the whole time you're trying to rush
rush rush because you're trying to get
to that next destination in time or
before your federally regulated time on
the road
runs out meanwhile you know you and your
um boss
and or your kind of
freight uh
company like ch robinson is trying to
find you your next load to pick up along
the way because you're kind of just like
most of these truckers are kind of just
like freelancers and they're just like
bouncing from point to point
um you know and that's the life of like
an independent trucker if you are a
trucker driving for one of these big
carriers and you're new to the industry
it's really like indentured servitude
you may owe them for the um training
that you got to become a truck driver
and you know so you've got like at least
a year contract with them that you can't
get out of and
you know you're working like 80 hours a
week and you're making
45 000 a year
and you never see your family well one
thing that uh one impact that your book
has had on my life is that i'm going to
definitely
think more carefully about changing
lanes in front of a truck on
the highway because you know clearly
like you say the physics of it is
complex and
i get the impression that truckers are
constantly being annoyed because they
try to leave some space in between their
truck and the car in front of them so
it's just a begging for people to like
cut in front of them but that's very
very dangerous apparently it is it's
it's the worst thing
never never cut in front of a truck
like don't pass a truck until they're at
least like you know a couple hundred
feet behind you is what i would say and
when you talk about like the number of
hours that they're uh working per day
and that's that's regulated by the
government and they can't cheat right
because they're being monitored it's in
this surveillance state this michel
foucault kind of thing where we're
keeping track with gps or whatever of
exactly how long they're on the road
every day yeah the same management the
same you know intensive monitoring by
technology and management by algorithm
that you find in
um you know amazon's warehouses you find
a different form of it
for truck drivers so yeah there's gps
there's like you know this little
computer that um you know is tracking
their time and look i mean it got put in
place
for reasons that are good which is that
people are like well we don't want
truckers driving too long that's unsafe
fine perfect good but the problem is
because truck drivers were used to the
old system where they could kind of
fudge their records you know maybe they
get to a warehouse and somebody's being
slow about loading their truck they're
going to hop in the back and take a nap
well now that nap still counts as their
workday so they're under the same
pressure to get loads from point a to
point b just as quickly but in a way
they have less flexibility about how
they do it
it's not yeah like i said it's a it's a
sort of dispiriting kind of picture of
of our world and the fact that about the
debates about the representation in
congress uh is an important one because
part of the sort of
standard solution to some of these
problems is you know yeah there's the
ruthless efficiency of capitalism that
is going to squeeze everything you can
out of these workers and then that's
supposed to be ameliorated by the
government setting some standards uh is
there hope whether it's in the amazon
fulfillment center in the trucking
industry for
uh more humane working conditions being
enforced by law
well
in the amazon warehouse california just
passed a bill
that
limits the quota systems that amazon
uses and its fulfillment centers and
amazon can't just pull out of california
so that's gonna have a significant
effect there as for truckers the only
provision that i'm aware of that's in
the infrastructure bill which may not
pass anyway
um came from the american trucking
association
and get this it is a request that they
lower the age
uh at which you can get a commercial
driver's license
from 21 to 18. so the ata is just like
hey
get us more cannon fodder
also teenagers with their
teenage brains are going to be driving
these you know enormous trucks on our
roads
um
so yeah i i
that industry seems very fragmented
very dysfunctional when you talk to
people who really understand it deeply
they're like they shake their heads and
they're like what are we gonna do and in
the meantime you know i
am genuinely concerned that it will lead
to
you know
problems in the supply chain that will
affect us all because
it's true you know by value of goods
it's like 90 90 plus percent of the
value of goods
that moves through america
it does it moves on trucks you know like
that old phrase like if trucks stop
america stops it's true if you can't get
it at your grocery store it's probably
because they couldn't find the trucker
to deliver it and there is this closely
related uh part of the system which is
the individual deliveries i don't even
know what the what terminology we use
here but the you the last mile the last
one yeah ups fedex and all that gps
fedex and also as you mentioned
companies like amazon might just be
building their own networks to do this
and you paint a very vivid picture of
once again how much pressure there is on
these drivers to be efficient to move
quickly and to get it done yeah i mean
there's there's tremendous pressure
and there's a lot of variability in that
industry in terms of how drivers are
treated
if you look at a company like ups you
know the company's more than 100 years
old it's unionized it's a real no joke
union it's the teamsters
um
you know it is it is what academics call
uh like business unionism where it's not
like the two are locked in a in battle
all the time like the union makes
concessions so that the business can
continue to run and be profitable and
everybody can have a job still but it
means that you know ups is pretty
conscientious about training their
drivers to be safe
about you know helping them if they get
into trouble with like too many packages
and such and then kind of on the other
end of the spectrum you have
fedex is all um subcontracted delivery
companies so none of their drivers are
unionized and then amazon just
copied fedex's model to build their own
last mile delivery network so when you
see those big like
you know gray vans with the amazon logo
on the side
that is a local company it's like a
franchisee almost a local company
that um
contracts with amazon and then on the
other end hired a bunch of drivers
you know amazon has recognized that the
pressure to deliver
so many packages so quickly
you know has affected
potentially the safety of those drivers
um
so their response typical amazon was
let's put more surveillance on the truck
like let's put more cameras facing out
and facing in so we can watch them be
unsafe the funny thing when you talk to
amazon about this whenever you ask them
like have you ever just considered likes
lowering the pace of work they're like
nah
that could just be bad messaging on
their part like i think that in
warehouses they probably are
doing that lowering the pace of work
sometimes because they can just it's
just a little toggle on some engineer's
dashboard somewhere like yeah fewer
widgets
um
but um
you know it's a lot of growing pains
because it's it's a company where
um i don't know if i would call it
growth at all cost but it's just a very
aggressive environment where it's like
everybody should perform at the highest
level all the time and if you can't do
it like we're just gonna cut you from
the team
um you know and and and maybe that works
when you're kind of the upstart and
you're challenging the world's retail
giants and e-commerce is a small
fraction of all of retail but like now
that it is
such a big proportion of it and they
gotta
you know it's it's like we all kind of
live and work in the company store like
the united states of amazon
you know the the way that people are
employed has to be changed i mean i
totally get the critique but i if i'm
honest i love amazon i use it all the
time and yeah i don't i try to spread
out my e-commerce and you know buy from
independent bookstores and things like
that as well but it's just so convenient
oh my goodness how can you help but buy
from amazon
well i mean
matthew glacier is the the former
founder of vox and political commentator
he said something which is funny but i
think true he's like sometimes
i
wish that um a company like amazon
would become so dominant because then it
would be easier to regulate this very
fragmented industry
of supply chains and it's like a fair
point you know because like trucking is
super fragmented and like
that hasn't helped those truck drivers
at all like if amazon had to own its
entire
trucking industry like
if you have a sane democracy like it
could make
you know setting out fair roles easier
and more possible and again when i talk
to amazon workers which i have with some
frequency they're they're not asking
people to boycott the company like the
nabisco workers who are like don't buy
you know um frosted mini wheats or
whatever um
they're just like we want to highlight
what's going on
because
you know we want working conditions to
improve so i don't know that it's about
amazon is evil and amazon needs to be
kicked to the curb i think it's more
like amazon represents this new reality
which you know frankly is being copied
by countless other companies whether
it's walmart or target or lowe's or
anybody who's moved into e-commerce
and
kind of as a society we need to take a
hard look at like what this means for
workers and the environment and
everything else and make decisions
informed decisions about how we want
to regulate that and when we don't want
to regulate it well now that we've
discussed how uh modern manufacturing
crushes people's souls let's not neglect
the fact that there are also interesting
math problems
that come up
which we like to talk about here on
mindscape and
you you just very briefly in the book
like like mention one fact that i
thought was fascinating and worth a
whole another book the
difference in the at the sort of level
of fedex or whatever between the hub and
spoke model where there's a few centers
that everyone drove to and everyone
drove from versus more of a mesh like as
a network theory person this is this is
fascinating we're we're somehow learning
on the fly how to optimize this network
uh in different ways and i'm wondering
how much of that is just trial and error
and how much of that is actually
mathematicians or or engineers computer
scientists thinking about this well if
you start to dig into the um supply
chain literature
the amount of
mathematics and engineering and computer
science in there is
really mind-boggling because it's these
big
meaty problems where if you can make a
fraction of a percentage point
difference in the efficiency of a port
or a delivery network or whatever it is
you can save somebody like tens of
millions of dollars
so
the companies in that industry invest
unreal amounts in in in the engineering
and the mathematics um i mean ups spent
300 million dollars this was like 20
years ago 300 million dollars just to
stand up
their orion software which um
you know dictates like the roots of ups
drivers every day to make their delivery
network as efficient as possible i mean
who knows how much they've spent since
then updating it probably
you know a comparable amount and that's
just ups like ups is not known to people
as like a technology company or anything
i mean if you just imagine how much r d
amazon spends to optimize its own
warehouses in its own um network like
yeah there's there's so much mathematics
and it and it's and it's all of these
you know
p versus mp like you could not solve
this problem
the traveling if you had the biggest
computer until the
yeah it's like you're not going to solve
this problem before the heat death of
the universe
so how do we approximate a good enough
answer
um so so it is it's definitely an
industry where um
that kind of math
uh
just makes such a big difference that
there's that there's so much thinking
about it and so many new models and the
application of new tools you know like
um
you know i i often think that ai is
really oversold but the most boring
applications of machine learning are
often the best
yeah
and you know predictive analytics
it's like it was
just born
to try to predict demand and predict
seasonal fluctuations in demand
and you know heat map where things need
to go in the most optimal way like it's
this is a great application for it
and
you spoke before about um so you i mean
you just mentioned the the ai the the
automation part of things let's sort of
uh wind things up with this a view of
the future and i i think there's two big
questions here one is what is the role
of increased automation
it's not going away we're not decreasing
the amount of automation right and then
is there some
sense in which uh any of these
innovations can actually help workers
can give them a bit more agency or is it
all just a downhill spiral from here on
in
yeah i mean i think what we're seeing in
the
kind of the nature of work in general is
this kind of polarization where like yes
the american middle class is getting
hollowed out
and yes a lot of people have been pushed
down the scale of income into jobs that
are more managed by algorithm
but also you know many many people have
been pushed up that income scale and are
doing jobs
that no machine can do right like
sometimes people talk about how do you
want to future proof yourself like well
like figure out how to solve problems
and be creative and get an education
because these are the things that
automation can't do for us
so i think the sort of the real kind of
challenge of our time is how do we make
sure that as we incorporate more and
more automation into our economy which
does make it more productive right which
can make life better for everybody in
theory it certainly produces more wealth
you know this is the obviously the sort
of big political issue of our time but i
think at a fundamental level it's it it
comes down to like
for a lot of people like just the
dignity of work and how much opportunity
they have
to make a living wage and have a
permanent or a stable job or not
um
and so i do think that
as we incorporate more and more
automation there is an opportunity to do
it in a humane way and there are
examples of this in other countries in
the us at other points in history where
automation has increased productivity
but people have enough agency and enough
security in their jobs
that it is a net benefit for them
um
but you know obviously we kind of
haven't been heading in that direction
for most of the last let's say
since the 70s
i do take
solace and the fact that like we are
experiencing now the so-called great
resignation
and people are kind of seem to be
re-evaluating their lives and have you
know some savings and and what else so
that they can
make these job
changes um i do think it's kind of
forcing a reckoning
uh and i am hopeful
that it will then force a lot of
companies on a lot of engineers
to look at the
on-the-ground impact of the automation
they've created
and um make it more humane and my final
thought on that is i actually know
somebody who turns out is the type of
like process engineer who does this kind
of stuff on a consulting basis
and she told me you know i've worked on
these warehouse systems before
i had
i'm so glad that i read this part of
your book because i'd never thought
about it from the perspective of the
worker this person is not a psychopath
or uh an unkind person it's just
their thinking about it in terms of my
job is to optimize this system
but you know we have to take this more
holistic view and maybe
to just get on the table the most
obvious thing that you didn't even
bother to say but there's this
very old idea which has always thus far
been wrong that if you decrease the
number of hours it takes to perform a
task people will do less work because
they don't need to do as much work to
get the same stuff done and you know
people a hundred years ago were
imagining that by now we would have
three hour work days and three day work
weeks uh but the work always expands to
fill the space in some sense right
because our demands always expand so
yeah i mean if we all were content with
you know
leading the live that our ancestors had
you know in the 1950s given the increase
in productivity since then like yeah we
could all work like three days a week
but we wouldn't have like um you know
kidney dialysis machines or mrna
vaccines
or the internet or anything else so
we just keep making our material culture
more complicated and the energy and
complexity embodied in you know our
consumer gadgets for example
represents all the extra labor that has
to be performed in order to maintain our
modern standard of living and there
seems to be no end to that so yeah
machines don't
take away jobs but they can change the
nature of those jobs for good or for ill
and i think understanding that
process and being aware of it
gives us the opportunity to kind of bend
the arc
of history toward
making work more humane and more
dignified you mentioned creative jobs
and i always you didn't say this but
let's just
air the idea
i do think that there's in some circles
a kind of utopian idea that maybe
someday we'll all be writers and poets
uh but once all the menial tasks have
been taken up by robots and and
computers
and i i think that's a very almost
elitist kind of attitude like i think
there are people who just don't want to
be writers and poets or you know they on
the one hand like to work on the other
hand they're happy to do something that
is sort of uh solid predictable work
because it's not their lives like they
get the meaning out of their lives
somewhere else they just want to go to
work do a good job and be safe like they
don't want to work in terrible
conditions but they're but they're not
you know rebelling against the fact that
they don't uh you know produce great
works of art and you had again one
little sentence in the book it's a very
uh rich book in terms of individual
threads you could pull out
where
amazon had a program where it would let
its workers uh trained to be higher
skilled uh laborers and number one
the the workers are like i don't have
time for this
you're working me too hard but number
two
the kinds of jobs they thought of
training for
were basically to be a truck driver it
wasn't to be a coder or or a manager
right and and
yeah the most popular certificate was
the truck drivers license and so
i don't know maybe you mentioned the
great resignation you know maybe we are
on the cusp of a transition where
some people won't have to work at all i
did a podcast episode with john danaher
who really just sort of intentionally
pushed the most utopian uh automation is
gonna free us from drudgery kind of
point of view but you need on the same
hand to have some
basic income or something like that and
maybe the stimulus checks were the first
step in that direction i mean so anyway
i've just blabbed a bunch of things do
you have some big picture visualization
of how the future of all this is going
to shake out let's say 50 years from now
i mean that i can't predict how it's
going to shake out because there's so
many contingencies that i can't
anticipate the impact of like you know
extreme weather and accelerating climate
change and stuff
but but i do think i do think you know
that we kind of have the opportunity to
um
yeah i mean work shouldn't be
exploitative it shouldn't be
unsustainable physically like these are
basic um
i mean it occurs to me in this moment
that maybe we should consider them
rights like a humane work environment
should be a right we certainly have the
resources the productivity in our
economy to accomplish that um and you
know
we used to have stronger labor
protections which sort of treated this
as a right
um i think if we move in that direction
yeah like look this whole idea that
we're gonna get fully automated luxury
communism or whatever you wanna call it
and everybody's just gonna um
be a poet like i got news for you like
half the people are just gonna sit
around like smoking weed all day and be
very unhappy like you know doing stuff
the the dignity of work
um is extremely important people need to
feel empowered by like i did this thing
and then here's the result like that is
that's that's instinctual for most of us
i think
so um yeah this idea that we're just
going to end work seems silly to me
and and it also just completely misreads
what automation does to economies and i
think that no matter where people are on
the political spectrum everybody gets
this wrong
it's so aggravating to me
it's like i want to write a whole book
about just this and other myths about
technology and its effects on society
and just be and just shake people and be
like look listen what technology does is
it changes the nature of work and we
need to be aware of the way it changes
the nature of work so that we can
continue to maintain like humane
dignified work and yeah not everybody
has to like derive their lives meaning
from work and frankly more of us should
stop trying to derive you know
our life's meaning from our work i think
that's the other thing that the great
resignation is about is like is people
pulling back and being like yeah i'm in
a creative profession but it doesn't
define me like i'm not my job like oh
maybe i should go connect with my
community maybe i should spend more time
with my family like
maybe i should have a hobby for the
first time in my life but so i want to i
want to complicate that i like
everything you just said only
complicated just a little bit um
in two ways one way is
i absolutely believe there are plenty of
people out there who derive dignity from
work even if it's not creative and
fulfilling in and of itself that the
very act of doing work and contributing
something and occupying that part of
your day is useful and we need to have
an economy that lets people do that in a
meaningful and well-compensated way on
the other hand there will be some people
who want to sit around and smoke weed or
sit around and play video games and
actually are happy because of that right
i mean and maybe that should be okay
like maybe we can change society and you
know like i say usually once we're past
the one hour mark in the podcast we can
just say any crazy thing we want can we
change
instead of saying that you know
automation and productivity
gets rid of jobs and work i mean maybe
it gets to the point where it allows us
to imagine changing society so much that
work becomes less of the the linchpin of
our lives i do like that idea and i do
think we need to do that because i think
that if you
i mean i have my undergraduate degree is
actually in anthropology and you know
one of
my professor's
favorite things to tell us about was
that you know hunter-gatherer societies
are the original affluent society like
the number of hours it takes you know a
kung san
tribes person to to gather enough
calories for the day
and and do their chores or whatever is
like four and the rest of the time
they're gonna sit around like you know
chewing the fat with their neighbors i
mean look we have had you go read the
book bowling alone like we've had this
real kind of tragedy
this death of civil society at the end
of the day i think because people are
just too busy so yeah like if we can
take some of this wealth and this
productivity we've created
and figure out how to distribute that
you know whether it's through higher
wages or
you know
other government subsidies or whatever
your political orientation leads you to
want to favor
um
then
yes i think we should aspire to return
to a world where
everyone doesn't have to work as hard
because we will have a
healthier world we'll have a healthier
planet we'll
hopefully reverse the trend of more and
more people reporting that they're
anxious and depressed every year i mean
i do think that we haven't
the industrialization of our economy and
taylorism and the spread of all of this
has created a
you know a cultish ideology that
everybody should just work work work
work more and the highest value is
you know
xyz measure of success and um you know
we
i don't think anybody actually most
people actually really don't want that
so whatever we can
build to get us there whether it's you
know universal basic income or however
people want to attempt to get there or
you know my favorite thing is like we
really should change our labor laws to
allow to make it easier for workers to
unionize again because i tell you what
that's how we got the 40-hour work week
that's a really fast way to get wages to
go up so that people don't have to work
as hard
whatever your preferred solution like
yeah we should do that everybody should
be working less i like it that's the
perfect place to end up so christopher
mims thanks so much for being on the
winescape podcast sean this is genuinely
a pleasure i you have had the best
questions of anybody so far all right
don't do any more this is it let's let's
go out on the top
[Music]
do
[Music]
you